I can't even tell you how many times
I've done this to myself I look down
sure stealing a little weird what's
wrong all this because it's on backwards
I ran over really quick to change my
shirt because I didn't like the one I
had and guess what well input Andre the
worst part about all this I actually
used to do this all the time when I was
little not only that I would put my
shoes on the wrong feet I didn't put my
shirt on backwards I come downstairs to
go to school and my mom would be like to
see what is wrong with you filter this
day I don't know my left and right but
it puts me on the spot like HR luck I
turn right every once in a while I'll
actually turn the correct way and it's
not because I don't know am I left and
right I got to really focus this one
makes the L this one's not making now
sometimes I'm slightly dyslexic when I'm
putting in phone number sometimes with
letters I screw things like that up all
the time and it's so frustrating because
it's the simplest things typing
somebody's phone number I just get all
flustered and I'm looking my phone and
they're looking at me and I'm putting it
in I'm sorry can you say that just just
one more time or five six or five I'm
sorry last you know and they just like
me and finally just ends up to the point
where I just give the person I felt like
you just put your phone number in here
it happens with names to is socks me
know one thing is is I don't really
there's anything that I can really do to
fix that I'm a grown adult at this point
if I can't figure out my left and right
on the spot it's not gonna happen it
only goes downhill from here guys
downhill from here oh yeah we're going
back to school maybe it'll start playing
brain age no my brain age ends up being
negative it's like your fetus so
congratulations I know I'm not alone i
know i am not because i know there's
probably some of you guys out there who
have the same problem can't help it and
people jock I know what's in this before
but you should never judge anybody
because you don't know what they're
going through what they're doing or what
is something something might not be
right anyway I am one
ring if you guys have any of these weird
quirks or things that you try to work
through and the you just successfully
good do it and to ensure that you're not
alone let's leave all those comments
below so that we can all talk it out and
know that we have each other and that's
all that we need is each that's not I
got a little song I don't think this was
actually originally supposed to be an
ask IJ episode until i turn my shirt
around the inside and it turned into
whatever this video happened to be I
don't even know azalea I